[Música]
jessica qué te gustaría hacer cuando
seas grande cantante chivísimo laosiana
que te gustaría hacer cuando seas grande
maestra super bien y vos kimberly sabes
qué quieren ser cuando seas grande no
todavía no tienes idea hay tiempo
sabían que según el observatorio laboral
de profesiones del consejo nacional de
rectores en el 2017 en costa rica un 68
punto 3 por ciento de las personas que
cursan carreras relacionadas con ciencia
y tecnología son hombres y sólo un 31.7
por ciento de las mujeres lo hacen
aunque el número de mujeres que cursan
carreras relacionadas con ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas ha
aumentado podemos notar que la brecha de
género todavía persiste
jessica es una niña de nueve años ella
vive en balsa de apenas una zona rural
del costa rica su mamá no sabe leer ni
escribir y trabaja en limpieza joana
ella vive en la virgen de sarapiquí a 90
kilómetros de la capital su mamá trabaja
lavando piñas en una piñera de la zona y
kimberly esa vida en río azul de
desamparados un barrio urbano marginal
aledaño la capital
su mamá es ama de casa ella se encarga
de las labores domésticas además de
cuidar a kimberley a sus tres hermanos
menores
estas chicas han formado parte de un
programa de empoderamiento de la mujer
por medio del uso de la tecnología
este programa abate de edades de entre
los 4 años hasta los 16 17 años de edad
más adultas que las acompañan en este
proceso se da a lo largo y ancho del
país en zonas rurales o con algún tipo
de riesgo social esto dentro del marco
de educación pública
se busca que estas mujeres piensen que
tienen el potencial para abordar áreas
que típicamente se han relacionado como
cosa de hombres y puedan representar de
esta manera a la mujer proporcionalmente
se trabaja con el rompimiento de ciertos
estereotipos de roles de género que se
nos han inculcado como el rol
reproductivo de la mujer de trabajo no
remunerado de cuido de servicio o el rol
productivo del hombre de trabajo que si
es remunerado de autoridad de poder
además se busca romper con estas cosas
que nos han dicho por medio por ejemplo
de la publicidad que son cosas para
niñas o cosas para niños
y con este tipo de iniciativa también se
quiere que las chicas tengan un
acercamiento inicial con la tecnología
por medio del uso de la robótica y la
programación en donde las chicas a lo
largo del proceso elaboran diferentes
tipos de proyectos
conocemos a esta mujer levante la mano
quien conoce esta mujer
bastantes algunos si alguno no les
cuento ella es sandra kofman ella es
ingeniera eléctrica y física
costarricense actualmente trabaja como
la directora de la división de las
ciencias de la tierra en la nasa cuando
ella quería estudiar
en la universidad quiso optar por la
carrera de ingeniería eléctrica sin
embargo le dijeron que no que no podía
por ser mujer que porque mejor no optaba
por ingeniería industrial es una
ingeniería más para mujeres y eso fue lo
que ella hizo y estudió ingeniería
industrial durante tres años aún sin ser
lo que ella realmente quería para
quienes no conocen la historia de sandra
los insto a que la busquen y terminen de
conocerla
que quiero decirles con este ejemplo que
esto de la diferencia al acceso a la
ciencia la tecnología la ingeniería y la
matemática por cuestión de género es
algo que ha ocurrido y sigue ocurriendo
y ha tenido implicaciones importantes en
nuestro país a nivel social por el papel
que se le ha dado a la mujer también a
nivel económico ya que el producto
interno bruto del país sería mayor si
más mujeres tuvieran trabajos
remunerados y de la misma forma a nivel
individual porque hay quienes no se han
podido desarrollar tal vez en lo que
realmente querían por circunstancias así
yo estoy segura que muchas mujeres no
sabían que eran potencialmente igual de
capaces que los hombres y que no
supieron que podían incursionar en el
campo que quisieran tan solo porque no
tuvieron a alguien que se lo dijera
o puede ser también que les pasara como
sandra que hubo alguien que les dijo eso
no es para ustedes o eso es cosa de
hombres
ya sea de forma explícita o
implícitamente
ok ya se había adelantado la diapositiva
entonces ya vieron que vamos a cantar
una canción ok yo sé que si ustedes la
conocen entonces la van a cantar conmigo
a ver dice así
arroz con leche cantemos
con una señorita de la capital que sepa
coser que sepa lavar que sepa abrir la
puerta para ir a jugar si cuanto se la
sabían levanten la mano cuanto se la
sabían todos y todas
este es un claro ejemplo de cómo la
sociedad patriarcal desde que estamos
muy pequeños nos enseñan aquellas cosas
que son cosas de hombres o cosas de
mujeres y otro ejemplo claro de este es
la educación yo no sé a cuántos de
ustedes les enseñó a leer ya escribir
una mujer
a mí también y cuantos de los que
estamos aquí presentes son educadores
levanten la mano
y cuantos de los que levantaron la mano
son mujeres
pues sí este es otro claro ejemplo de
roles que nos ha impuesto la sociedad de
la misma manera lo hizo con el
desarrollo científico y con el
desarrollo tecnológico pero fue algo que
se le dio mayormente a los hombres
pensemos qué pasaría si pudiéramos
mostrarles a más y más mujeres
especialmente aquellas de zonas rurales
con menor acceso a la información o en
donde la masculinidad hegemónica
conocida popularmente como machismo está
más marcado mostrar los que son capaces
de incursionar en estas áreas y de esta
manera ampliar les el espectro de
oportunidades a las que cuáles podrán
acceder en un futuro
además es muy importante que podamos
darles herramientas desde la educación
como en habilidades blandas empatía
asertividad comunicación y además
decirles que ellas si pueden incursionar
en esto y tienen la misma capacidad para
hacerlo que cualquiera también con
diferentes iniciativas o dentro de los
mismos centros educativos podemos
incentivar las a que cursen en áreas
estén de ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemática ahora conocido como steam con
la inserción de la de arte para darle un
enfoque más integral dato curioso sting
palabra que significa vapor en español y
así al igual que lo hace el vapor
podamos abarcar más habilidades para
empoderar a estas chicas y que tengan
desde pequeñas hasta su futuro
es nuestra responsabilidad como docentes
decirle a las chicas las gamas de
carreras en el área es tim a las que
pueden acceder e impulsar les a que
continúen estudiando chicas que tal vez
tenían como aspiración máxima terminar
el colegio o sacar un técnico de repente
quieran cursar la universidad o porque
no incluso buscar una beca para poder
estudiar en el exterior
chicas que creían que no podían salir de
una realidad y que se sientan capaces de
que pueden tener otra distinta
además mujeres que tal vez nunca habían
tenido ni siquiera un contacto previo
con la tecnología se dieron cuenta que
si pudieran tenerlo y que incluso les
gustó y sin importar la edad pudieron
aprender
es ahí por donde tenemos que continuar
trabajando desde la educación para que
las chicas aumenten su nivel de
educación y de esta manera su inserción
en el campo laboral
esto nos ayudaría también a bajar lo que
son las tasas de diferencias que existen
en la tasa de desempleo por género
no va a favorecer sólo a nivel social
sino que va a favorecer a nivel
económico al país
jessica que te gustaría estudiar cuando
seas grande programación excelente y a
vos joana que te gustaría te gustaría
ser docente todavía me encanta súper
bien
y vos kimberly ya tenés alguna idea más
clara de que te gustaría ser doctora
guau
ahora es importante que quede claro que
mediante esta información que le vamos a
brindar a las chicas no queremos que
todas se conviertan en ingenieras o que
cambien necesariamente todo su esquema
de creencias pero sí que tengan la
oportunidad de conocer estas
posibilidades y que rompan con una serie
de estereotipos de género que se nos
inculcan muchas veces desde que somos
muy pequeños ahora yo no sé a ustedes
pero a mí no me gustó la canción que
cantamos ahora al menos esa versión no
entonces qué les parece si si les enseño
ahora una versión un poco diferente que
yo inventé y que podemos enseñárselo a
otras personas para que sea la nueva
versión de arroz con leche ok me ayudan
a cantar va a estar la letra así es que
pueden leerla
y dice así
arroz con leche que vamos cantemos
muy bien una mujer valiente que se va a
luchar
y quiere aprender quiera estudiar
valerse por sí misma y así
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]